hello so for the last two years I've
been making my own little video blogger
runs in this little box that you see
behind me we've known each other long
enough you know I feel comfortable
having you around so I think it's about
time that I showed you around the crib
so here you go come on in this is my
computer suite this is where I do the
editing stuff that you see that amazing
bit of editing there or I kind of
appeared was done right here on mr.
shiny my monitor I think you'll agree
the most important part of any computer
suite is to have a little guard dog to
guard your computer while you're not
around this is Trevor the dog say hi
Trevor what's that oh he's not real so
he can't talk the real most important
part of any computer area is the spinny
chair here's a little game that I've
been playing with my spinny chair
recently it's called happy face sad face
okay as much as I love the spinny chair
I don't actually like spinning around in
it because it makes me sick I'm gonna go
and have some water something you
probably already noticed this thing is
my wall of things it's not an essential
part of the computer suite I should
really stop calling it the computer
suite but sticking things on your wall
is a very important hobby to have if
you're a teenager let's have a closer
look this is a Christmas card that my
friend Tom made me that I thought was
quite funny coincidentally this is also
the only Christmas card that I got to
that year about a year ago here in Bath
they had loads of model pigs everywhere
and this is my favorite it's called
bigger bites I also have a video of my
friend Alex humping this pig which I
will put in here because it's quite
funny this is a drawing that was sent to
me by squiggle now this is by Nathan way
Byrne and I stuck some 3d glasses on it
because I am quirky like that this is a
picture of my friend Patrick with a cake
on his face this is a picture of my
brother that I took on my phone and then
kind of made all weird and then actually
painted into a picture found it yeah
painting woo this is my bedside table
fairly standard and boring I think you
will agree
apart from my alarm clock I have a lot
of trouble waking up in the morning so I
found a list of the top 10 most annoying
alarm clocks and this was number one he
has wheels so basically what he does is
he runs off my bedside
table hides in my bedroom and then I'm
forced to get out of bed and find him
which as a result wakes me up gonna go
he's such a confused little thing these
are some books not too much going on
here apart from the ultimate lego book I
mean look at that that is made from Lego
I I love this book it's so cool look at
this is a little bit more interesting
here we have Paper Towns by John Green a
load of CDs that I don't listen to
anymore and we also have this which is
objectified which is a documentary about
objects and their relationship with
humans because I'm a massive dork you
have reached level 3 of my bookcase
these are the more exciting CDs that we
have right here parents stories by Alex
day taking leave by Alan the stuff guy
and Tom Milsom Greg Holden a word in
edgeways
the sinners lust for life but I also
have this which is really lame this is
chameleon circuit right they play songs
about Doctor Who what weirdos and
finally level 4 these armor Mario
mushrooms I got this one from New York
this one was given to me a YouTube game
room and this one was bought for me by a
friend
this is Luigi who I bought from Nintendo
World in New York and then we have the
TARDIS and the doctor both given to me
at a YouTube gathering and a Dalek who
actually doubles as a shampoo bottle and
then we have my wardrobe which is too
much of a mess to even try and explore
that's about it that is my bedroom I
have a feeling that the concept of
making a video about your bedroom is
easily copyable so if you wish to post a
video response of your own crib please
do bye you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like cool